ברוכים הבאים חזרה להבנת מידע קוונטי וחישוב קוונטי שמי הוא John watus ואני המנהל הטכני לחינוך
ב-IBM Quantum זה השיעור התשיעי בסדרה וזה השיעור הראשון ביחידה השלישית שעוסקת בניסוח
הכללי של מידע קוונטי עד עכשיו השתמשנו בניסוח המפושט של
מידע קוונטי שבו מצבים קוונטיים מיוצגים על ידי וקטורים מרוכבים עם נורמה אוקלידית השווה ל-
אחד לעומת זאת בניסוח הכללי של מידע קוונטי מצבים קוונטיים מיוצגים על ידי
מטריצות מסוג מסוים שנקראות מטריצות צפיפות השיעור הראשון של היחידה מתמקד במטריצות צפיפות באופן ספציפי
ונגיע למה שהן ואיך הן עובדות ככל שהשיעור ממשיך מטריצות צפיפות הן מאוד
שימושיות והן מציעות יתרונות שונים שנדון בהם הן מאפשרות לנו לייצג סוג
רחב יותר של מצבים ממה שוקטורי מצב קוונטיים יכולים כולל מצבים של מערכות שהושפעו מרעש למשל וכן בחירות אקראיות
של מצבים קוונטיים נסתכל גם על כדור Bloch שנותן לנו דרך גיאומטרית מאוד יפה
ופשוטה לחשוב על מצבי qubit ונראה איך הוא מתחבר למטריצות צפיפות בצורה
מרשימה למדי דרך מטריצות Pauli לבסוף נדון במטריצות צפיפות בהקשר של מערכות
מרובות ובפרט נראה איך הן מאפשרות לנו לתאר מצבים קוונטיים של מערכות שנצפות בבידוד גם כאשר
הן מתואמות עם מערכות אחרות וזה כולל את האפשרות שהן שזורות עם מערכות אחרות זה דבר חשוב שצריך להיות
מסוגלים לעשות וזה לא נעשה בקלות בתוך הניסוח המפושט של מידע קוונטי הנה סקירה של
השיעור נתחיל עם היסודות של מטריצות צפיפות כולל הגדרות רלוונטיות וכמה דוגמאות וגם
נדון באיך הן מתחברות לוקטורי מצב קוונטיים אחר כך נדבר על צירופים קמורים של מטריצות צפיפות או במילים
אחרות מה קורה כשלוקחים ממוצעים משוקללים של מטריצות צפיפות נתחיל עם דוגמה ספציפית
של מה שנקרא המצב המעורב לחלוטין נראה איך מצבים הסתברותיים קלאסיים יכולים להיחשב כ-
מקרים פרטיים של מטריצות צפיפות ונדון באיך המשפט הספקטרלי מאלגברה לינארית נכנס לתמונה
בהקשר הזה החלק השלישי של השיעור הוא על כדור Bloch שמספק דרך גיאומטרית להסתכל על מצבים של
qubit בודד כפי שהזכרתי בתחילת השיעור ובחלק הרביעי של השיעור נדבר על איך מטריצות צפיפות עובדות עבור מערכות
מרובות נדון במצבי מכפלה ובמצבים מתואמים מסוגים שונים כולל מצבים שזורים וגם
המושג של מצב מצומצם שהוא תיאור על ידי מטריצת צפיפות של מצב החלק המבודד של מערכת מורכבת
שניתן לחשב באמצעות פעולה שנקראת העקבה החלקית לפני שנגיע לתוכן הטכני של השיעור עצמו זה
מתאים לקחת כמה רגעים כדי להניע את השימוש במטריצות צפיפות באמצעות הניסוח
המפושט של מידע קוונטי שלא כולל מטריצות צפיפות אנחנו יכולים לתאר אלגוריתמים קוונטיים כמו
האלגוריתם של Shor לפירוק לגורמים למשל בלי שום קשיים אז למה בכלל להתעסק עם מטריצות צפיפות
או הניסוח הכללי הזה של מידע קוונטי בכלל ובכן יש כמה סיבות לכך ראשית מטריצות צפיפות
מייצגות סוג רחב יותר של מצבים קוונטיים מאשר וקטורי מצב קוונטיים כולל מצבים קוונטיים שבהם יש אי-ודאות או
אקראיות זה חשוב כשרוצים לדמות את ההשפעות של רעש על חישובים קוונטיים
למשל שנית באמצעות מטריצות צפיפות אנחנו יכולים לתאר מצבים קוונטיים של חלקים מבודדים של מערכות מורכבות כמו
מצבים של מערכות שזורות עם מערכות אחרות שאולי לרגע אנחנו בוחרים להתעלם מהן כפי שהזכרתי בתחילת
השיעור זה לא נעשה בקלות או באופן טבעי בתוך הניסוח המפושט של מידע
קוונטי סיבה שלישית היא שכאשר משתמשים במטריצות צפיפות מידע קלאסי למעשה צומח כ-
מקרה פרטי אז במקום שיהיה לנו מה שבעצם הוא אנלוגיה בין מצבים הסתברותיים ופעולות מ-
צד אחד לבין וקטורי מצב קוונטיים ופעולות יוניטריות מצד שני יש לנו מידע קוונטי וקלאסי
שמתוארים יחד בתוך מסגרת מתמטית אחת שזה כמעט הכרחי לחקירה המתמטית
של מידע קוונטי אז אם אתם רציניים לגבי הבנת מידע קוונטי ברמה מתמטית מאוד
מומלץ שתלמדו על מטריצות צפיפות בואו נתחיל עם ההגדרה של מטריצות
צפיפות לצורך ההגדרה נניח ש-X היא מערכת וסיגמא היא קבוצת המצבים הקלאסיים שלה ונזכיר שכאשר
משתמשים במונח הזה ההנחה שלנו היא שסיגמא היא סופית ולא ריקה וכמו תמיד אפשר לבחור
שמות שונים אם רוצים מטריצת צפיפות שמתארת מצב של המערכת X היא מטריצה עם ערכים
מרוכבים שהשורות והעמודות שלה הועמדו בהתאמה עם קבוצת המצבים הקלאסיים שלה וכדי להיות ברורים
זו אותה התאמה עבור השורות והעמודות בו-זמנית זה אומר שמטריצות
צפיפות הן תמיד מטריצות ריבועיות ובנוסף להיותן ריבועיות יש כמה תנאים שצריכים להתקיים
ונגיע אליהם בקרוב אנשים בדרך כלל משתמשים באותיות יווניות קטנות מסוימות כדי לקרוא שם למטריצות
צפיפות רו היא בדרך כלל הבחירה הראשונה ובחירות נפוצות אחרות כוללות סיגמא קטנה ו-טאו שמוצגות על
המסך זו רק מוסכמה אבל כרגיל מוסכמות כאלה עוזרות כי הן הופכות דברים ליותר
קלים לזיהוי ועכשיו בואו נדבר על התנאים או הדרישות שמטריצות צפיפות צריכות לקיים כדי להיות
מטריצות צפיפות תקפות יש שניים מהם ומה שאעשה זה קודם פשוט לרשום אותם
ואז אדון ביתר פירוט במה שהם אומרים התנאי הראשון הוא שמטריצות
צפיפות חייבות שיהיה להן עקבה יחידתית או במילים אחרות עקבה השווה לאחד והתנאי השני הוא ש-
מטריצות צפיפות חייבות להיות חיוביות למחצה ובשני המקרים יש לנו דרכים סימבוליות תמציתיות לבטא
את שני התנאים האלה שמופיעות על המסך עכשיו בואו אדון בשני התנאים ביתר פירוט
התנאי הראשון מתייחס לעקבה שהיא פונקציה חשובה מאוד שמוגדרת לכל המטריצות הריבועיות
והיא פשוט הסכום של האיברים באלכסון והנה משוואה שמבטאת את זה
באופן מפורש עכשיו יש הרבה מה לומר על העקבה ולמה היא חשובה אבל בינתיים בואו רק נשים לב
לתכונה אחת בסיסית מאוד שלה והיא שזו פונקציה לינארית תכונות אחרות של העקבה יעלו ונדון בהן כש-
יהיה צורך אבל כדי לשמור על המיקוד שלנו על מטריצות צפיפות בואו נעבור לדרישה השנייה והדרישה הזו היא ש-
מטריצות צפיפות הן חיוביות למחצה זה גם מושג חשוב שעולה בהרבה הקשרים ב-
פיזיקה כימיה אופטימיזציה למידת מכונה ותחומים אחרים וזה יכול להיות מבוטא בכמה דרכים שונות אבל
שקולות דרך אחת לבטא את זה היא לומר שמטריצה רו היא חיובית למחצה אם קיימת מטריצה M
כך שרו שווה ל-M דאגר כפול M ומתברר שלא משנה אם נדרוש שגם M עצמה תהיה
מטריצה ריבועית או אם נוותר על ההגבלה הזו דרך אחרת לבטא מה זה אומר שמטריצה רו היא חיובית
למחצה היא לומר שרו היא הרמיטית מה שאומר שהיא שווה לשחלוף הצמוד שלה וכל
הערכים העצמיים שלה הם מספרים ממשיים אי-שליליים באופן כללי למטריצות הרמיטיות יכולים להיות
רק ערכים עצמיים ממשיים אבל הם יכולים להיות שליליים אבל אם נוסיף את ההגבלה הנוספת שאף אחד מ-
הערכים העצמיים לא יכול להיות שלילי נקבל את המטריצות החיוביות למחצה ודרך אגב אם נתונה
לכם מטריצה ואתם רוצים לדעת אם היא חיובית למחצה אז אפשר לקבוע את זה באמצעות האפיון הזה די קל
לבדוק אם מטריצה היא הרמיטית או לא זה משהו שאפשר לראות בעין יותר קשה לחשב
את הערכים העצמיים אבל זה משהו שלא קשה מדי לעשות עם מחשב כי יש אלגוריתמים מאוד יעילים לעשות
את זה והאפיון האחרון שאזכיר למרות שיש אחרים הוא שלכל וקטור עמודה s שמספר
הרכיבים שלו מתאים למספר השורות ומספר העמודות של רו אי-השוויון שמוצג על
המסך מתקיים במילים בראי כפול רו כפול קטסאי חייב להיות מספר ממשי אי-
שלילי דרך אגב זה לא מובן מאליו שהאפיונים האלה כולם שקולים אבל הם כן ותנו לי לציין באופן מפורש שה-
סימון שאנחנו משתמשים בו בדרך כלל כדי לציין שמטריצה רו היא חיובית למחצה נראה כמו רו גדולה
או שווה לאפס אבל זה רק סימון מקוצר וזה לא אומר ממש שרו גדולה מ-
או שווה לאפס רו היא מטריצה אז זה לא היה הגיוני וזה לא אומר
שכל אחד מהאיברים של רו גדול או שווה לאפס בפרט יש מטריצות חיוביות
למחצה שהאיברים שלהן לא כולם אי-שליליים ויש מטריצות שהאיברים שלהן כולם אי-
שליליים אבל הן לא חיוביות למחצה הרעיון מאחורי הסימון הוא שמטריצות חיוביות למחצה
הן כמו אנלוגים מטריציאליים של מספרים ממשיים אי-שליליים אבל זה רק סימון ומה שהוא אומר הוא
בדיוק מה שכבר דנו בו עכשיו בואו נסתכל על כמה דוגמאות נתחיל עם דוגמה של
מטריצה חיובית למחצה למעשה די קל ליצור באקראי דוגמה של
מטריצה חיובית למחצה פשוט על ידי בחירת מטריצה M שרירותית ואז חישוב M דאגר כפול
M למשל הנה מטריצה M שהיא לא מיוחדת במיוחד ולמעשה
יצרתי את המטריצה הזו באקראי על ידי בחירה עצמאית של החלקים הממשיים והמדומים של האיברים כמספרים שלמים בין מינוס 9 לפלוס
9 אז כל תבנית או מבנה כאן הם מקריים לחלוטין על ידי הכפלת
השחלוף הצמוד של M ב-M נקבל את המטריצה הזו כאן שהיא לכן חיובית
למחצה כמובן יש גבול לכמה תובנה אפשר לקבל מדוגמה אקראית אבל היא כן מציגה כמה
תכונות שנפוצות למטריצות חיוביות למחצה באופן כללי יותר בפרט תשימו לב
שהאיברים באלכסון כלומר אלה שלאורך הקו מהפינה השמאלית העליונה לפינה הימנית התחתונה הם כולם מספרים ממשיים אי-שליליים
ובנוסף האיברים מחוץ לאלכסון הם איכשהו לא גדולים מדי בהשוואה לאיברי האלכסון המתאימים
כלומר זה שבאותה שורה וזה שבאותה עמודה כמו כל איבר מחוץ לאלכסון שאנחנו מסתכלים
עליו יש עוד לסיפור הזה אבל חשוב להכיר בכך שלהיות חיובית למחצה היא
תכונה של המטריצה בכללותה ולא רק תנאי על איברים בודדים אז זו דוגמה של
מטריצה חיובית למחצה ואפשר בקלות רבה ליצור דוגמאות אחרות בשיטה
דומה עכשיו בואו נסתכל על כמה דוגמאות של מטריצות צפיפות שבהן בנוסף לתנאי חיובית למחצה יש לנו גם שהעקבה שווה
לאחד הנה כמה דוגמאות של מטריצות צפיפות 2 על 2 העקבה שווה ל-
אחד בכל ארבעת המקרים ואנחנו גם יכולים לראות שאלה מטריצות הרמיטיות אז בעזרת האפיון השני של
מטריצות חיוביות למחצה מקודם כל שנשאר הוא לבדוק שהערכים העצמיים כולם אי-שליליים
אני אשאיר את זה לכם לבדוק אם תרצו עבור מטריצות 2 על 2 זה לא קשה מדי לחשב ערכים עצמיים ביד
אבל אפשר גם פשוט לבקש ממחשב לעשות את זה למשל אפשר להשתמש בפונקציית eigVal בחבילת האלגברה הלינארית
של Python אפשר גם לקבל מטריצת צפיפות פשוט על ידי לקיחת כל מטריצה
חיובית למחצה שונה מאפס וחלוקתה בעקבה שלה למשל הנה מטריצת הצפיפות שנקבל על ידי
חלוקת הדוגמה שראינו לפני כמה רגעים בעקבה שלה חלוקה בעקבה כזו
תמיד תשמור על התכונה חיובית למחצה ובוודאות נקבל מטריצה עם עקבה השווה לאחד מתוקף העובדה ש-
העקבה היא פונקציה לינארית זו רק אוסף קטן של דוגמאות ונראה עוד ככל שהשיעור
ממשיך בשלב הבא ניקח כמה רגעים לדון בפרשנות או
המשמעות האינטואיטיבית של מטריצות צפיפות הדבר הראשון שצריך להכיר בו הוא שזה אולי נראה קצת יוצא דופן
שאנחנו מייצגים את המצב של מערכת עם מטריצה ולא עם וקטור לעומת זאת בניסוח
המפושט של מידע קוונטי אנחנו משתמשים בוקטורים כדי לייצג מצבים בעוד שמטריצות ובפרט מטריצות יוניטריות
מייצגות פעולות או אופרציות ככה המתמטיקה עובדת ולמרות שתמיד אפשר
לחשוב על מטריצות כמתארות העתקות לינאריות אנחנו לא בדרך כלל מייחסים משמעות אינטואיטיבית ישירה
להעתקה הלינארית המשויכת למטריצת צפיפות נתונה עם זאת העובדה ש-
מטריצות צפיפות הן אכן מטריצות מתבררת כהיבט קריטי חשוב שלהן ונראה
את זה ככל שנמשיך אבל רק להזכיר דוגמה אחת לעכשיו הערכים העצמיים של מטריצת צפיפות נתונה
מתבררים כחשובים מאוד כי הם מתארים כמה אקראיות או אי-ודאות טמונה במצב
שמטריצת הצפיפות הזו מתארת דרך אחרת לחשוב על מטריצות צפיפות ברמה אינטואיטיבית
מתמקדת באיברים של המטריצות האלה זכרו שהשורות והעמודות של מטריצות צפיפות מועמדות
בהתאמה עם המצבים הקלאסיים של כל מערכת שעליה אנחנו מדברים אז לכל איבר יש לנו
מצב קלאסי אחד שמתאים לשורה של האיבר ומצב קלאסי אחד שמתאים לעמודה של
האיבר עבור האיברים באלכסון שני המצבים הקלאסיים האלה הם אותו מצב וזו הסיבה שהאיברים באלכסון הם
מיוחדים ודרך אחת לפרש את האיברים באלכסון היא שהם הסתברויות ובאופן ספציפי הם
ההסתברויות שהמצב הקלאסי המתאים יופיע אם נבצע מדידה בבסיס הסטנדרטי
על המערכת שאת המצב הקוונטי שלה אנחנו מתארים עבור האיברים שמחוץ לאלכסון מצד שני יש לנו מצב קלאסי אחד שמתאים לשורה
של האיבר ומצב קלאסי שונה שמתאים לעמודה של האיבר ובאופן לא פורמלי מאוד
האיברים האלה מתארים את המידה שבה שני המצבים הקלאסיים האלה נמצאים בסופרפוזיציה קוונטית וגם את
הפאזה היחסית ביניהם זה אולי יהיה יותר הגיוני ככל שהשיעור ממשיך ונסתכל יותר
לעומק על כמה דוגמאות ספציפיות והפרטים אולי לא ברורים בשלב הזה אבל בבקשה אל תתנו לזה להפריע
לכם זה די לא פורמלי וזה רק נועד להיות רעיון אינטואיטיבי שכדאי לשמור מאחורי
הראש בשלב הבא נסתכל על הקשר בין מטריצות צפיפות לוקטורי מצב קוונטיים שהם וקטורי
עמודה עם נורמה אוקלידית השווה לאחד רק כדי להזכיר את ההגדרה המתמטית נניח שיש לנו
וקטור מצב קוונטי פסאי שמייצג את המצב של מערכת מסוימת מטריצת הצפיפות שמייצגת את אותו
מצב קוונטי נתונה על ידי קט פסאי כפול בראסאי כפי שמוצג כאן על המסך כדי להיות ברורים לגבי זה האינדקסים של פסאי
מתאימים בצורה כלשהי למצבים הקלאסיים של כל מערכת שעליה אנחנו מדברים וזו תהיה בדיוק אותה התאמה שיש לנו בין
השורות והעמודות של מטריצת הצפיפות שלנו לבין המצבים הקלאסיים של המערכת אם נדמיין שיש n
מצבים קלאסיים של המערכת ונחשוב על וקטורי עמודה ושורה כמטריצות אז קט פסאי הוא מטריצה n על 1
ובראסאי הוא מטריצה 1 על n אז כשנבצע את הכפל נקבל מטריצה n על n
זו תמיד תהיה מטריצה חיובית למחצה רק מהצורה שלה למעשה והיא גם תהיה עם עקבה השווה
לאחד מתוקף העובדה שפסאי הוא וקטור יחידה ונראה את זה ביתר פירוט
בקרוב מצבים קוונטיים שמיוצגים על ידי מטריצות צפיפות בצורה הזו נקראים מצבים
טהורים הנה כמה דוגמאות קודם בואו ניקח את המצב
הזה כאן שהוא קצת כמו מצב פלוס חוץ מזה שהאיבר שמתאים למצב הקלאסי אחד הוא
מדומה אם נחשב את השחלוף הצמוד נקבל סימן מינוס כי הצמוד המרוכב של i הוא
מינוס i ואם נבצע את הכפל נקבל את המטריצה שמוצגת כאן על המסך היא הרמיטית כפי שאפשר
לראות מיד רק על ידי הסתכלות עליה ויש לה במקרה ערך עצמי אחד השווה לאחד וערך עצמי אחד השווה ל-
אפס אז היא חיובית למחצה והעקבה שלה שווה לאחד אז היא אכן מטריצת צפיפות כפי
שציפינו אפשר לחשב את מטריצות הצפיפות המתאימות לבסיס הסטנדרטי ולבסיסי הפלוס מינוס בצורה דומה ומטריצות הצפיפות האלה
מוצגות כאן והנה עוד דוגמה של וקטור מצב קוונטי שבמקרה
הופיע עוד בשיעור הראשון של הסדרה ואם נחשב את השחלוף הצמוד ואז נכפיל
נקבל את מטריצת הצפיפות שמוצגת כאן שוב היא הרמיטית ויש לה
עקבה השווה לאחד ואם תחשבו את הערכים העצמיים תמצאו שגם כאן יש ערך עצמי אחד השווה לאחד וערך עצמי אחד
השווה לאפס ודרך אגב זה מאפיין נפוץ של כל המצבים הטהורים תמיד יש להם ערך עצמי אחד
השווה לאחד ושאר הערכים העצמיים כולם אפס באופן כללי עבור וקטור מצב קוונטי שרירותי לחלוטין
פסאי עם כל מספר של רכיבים אם נכפיל קט פסאי בבראסאי נקבל
מטריצת צפיפות שנראית ככה שימו לב בפרט שהאיברים באלכסון הם תמיד אחד מ-
איברי פסאי מוכפל בצמוד המרוכב שלו שאפשר לחלופין לבטא כערך מוחלט בריבוע של האיבר וזה
דרך אחת לראות שהעקבה תמיד תהיה שווה לאחד זה גם עקבי עם ההערה שעשיתי קודם בשיעור על
האיברים באלכסון של מטריצת צפיפות שאומרים לנו מה ההסתברויות לראות כל מצב קלאסי אפשרי
אם נבצע מדידה בבסיס הסטנדרטי והערה אחרונה
אין בעיה של פאזות גלובליות עם מטריצות צפיפות שני מצבים קוונטיים זהים אם ורק אם מטריצות
הצפיפות שלהם שוות בפרט נניח שיש לנו שני וקטורי מצב קוונטיים פסאי ופי ש-
שווים עד כדי פאזה גלובלית מה שאומר שאפשר לבטא את אחד מהם פי נגיד כשני כפול
מספר מרוכב כלשהו על מעגל היחידה אם נחשב את ייצוג מטריצת הצפיפות של פי אז מה שנמצא
הוא שגורם הפאזה הגלובלי מוכפל בצמוד המרוכב שלו וזה נותן לנו אחד אז הוא
למעשה נעלם ונשארים עם בדיוק אותה מטריצת צפיפות שנקבל מפסאי אז זה סוג של
בונוס קטן נחמד ובאופן כללי יותר אין שום בעיה עם שקילות עד כדי פאזות גלובליות בכלל כש-
עובדים עם מטריצות צפיפות זה בעצם ניוון שקיים כשמשתמשים בוקטורי מצב קוונטיים ולא
במטריצות צפיפות כדי לייצג מצבים קוונטיים מטריצות צפיפות מחזיקות בתכונה מפתח שהיא שצירופים קמורים
של מטריצות צפיפות מייצגים בחירות הסתברותיות או אקראיות של מצבים
קוונטיים דרך אחרת לומר את זה היא שאפשר לממצע מטריצות צפיפות יחד בצורה משמעותית מה שלא
ניתן לעשות עם וקטורי מצב קוונטיים כדי להסביר את זה ביתר פירוט בואו נתחיל עם המצב שבו
יש לנו שתי מטריצות צפיפות רו וסיגמא שמייצגות מצבים קוונטיים של מערכת כלשהי בואו נדמיין שה-
מערכת מוכנה במצב רו בהסתברות p עבור בחירה כלשהי של p בין אפס לאחד ואחרת
המערכת מוכנה במצב סיגמא למשל אולי p הוא חצי אז אנחנו
יכולים לדמיין שמישהו מטיל מטבע הוגן ואם יוצא עץ הוא מבצע תהליך כלשהו שמשאיר את המערכת ב-
מצב רו ואחרת אם המטבע יוצא פלי הוא מבצע תהליך אחר שמשאיר את המערכת ב-
מצב סיגמא השאלה עכשיו היא מהו המצב של המערכת ולהיות ברורים
אנחנו מתעניינים במצב של המערכת בבידוד תוך התעלמות מכל מידע אחר שאולי קיים לגבי
איזו הכנה בוצעה למשל דמיינו שאין לנו גישה למטבע או ל-
זיכרון של מי שביצע את הכנת המצב והתשובה לשאלה הזו היא שזה פשוט הממוצע המשוקלל של שתי מטריצות
הצפיפות p כפול רו ועוד 1 מינוס p כפול סיגמא זה דרך אגב לחלוטין
אנלוגי למה שהיה לנו אם רו וסיגמא לא היו מטריצות צפיפות אלא וקטורי הסתברות
שמייצגים מצבים הסתברותיים אז זה לא משהו מזעזע או מסתורי אלא זה משהו
שאולי מוכר מתורת ההסתברות אנחנו עושים ממוצעים כאלה כל הזמן כשמחשבים הסתברויות וחושבים
על בחירות אקראיות קלאסיות והנקודה היא שזה עובד גם עבור מטריצות צפיפות אבל שימו לב שזה לא
עובד עבור וקטורי מצב קוונטיים כלומר לא ניתן באופן כללי לממצע שני וקטורי מצב
קוונטיים ככה ולקוות לקבל וקטור מצב קוונטי תקף ואם תנסו בדרך כלל תקבלו וקטור ש-
אין לו נורמה אוקלידית השווה לאחד עם מטריצות צפיפות לעומת זאת ממוצעים משוקללים כאלה תמיד
יהיו מטריצות צפיפות תקפות וחשוב יותר מטריצת הצפיפות שתקבלו תייצג את הבחירה האקראית הזו
בצורה משמעותית זה מוכלל לבחירות אקראיות שבהן יש יותר משתי
חלופות בפרט אם יש לנו M מטריצות צפיפות אפשריות ווקטור הסתברות עם M רכיבים אחד
לכל מטריצת צפיפות ומערכת מוכנה בכל מצב אפשרי עם ההסתברות המתאימה
אז הממוצע המשוקלל של מטריצות הצפיפות האלה מתאר את המצב שנוצר של המערכת ודרך אגב כש-
אנחנו מתייחסים לצירוף קמור של מטריצות צפיפות זה מה שאנחנו מתכוונים צירוף קמור הוא פשוט צירוף
לינארי שבו המקדמים יוצרים וקטור הסתברות זו תמיד תהיה מטריצת
צפיפות ודרך פשוטה ותמציתית לומר את זה במונחים מתמטיים היא שקבוצת כל מטריצות הצפיפות
המתאימות למערכת נתונה היא קבוצה קמורה אז אם יש לנו נגיד M וקטורי מצב
קוונטיים פסאי 0 עד פסאי M מינוס אחד יחד עם הסתברויות p0 עד pM מינוס אחד שביחד יוצרים
וקטור הסתברות ומערכת מוכנה במצב פסאי k בהסתברות pk לכל k אז
המצב שנוצר של המערכת מתואר על ידי מטריצת הצפיפות שמוצגת כאן על המסך בפרט אנחנו לא ממצעים
את וקטורי המצב הקוונטיים עצמם אלא אנחנו ממצעים את מטריצות הצפיפות
המתאימות באופן כללי מצב כזה לא יהיה לו ייצוג כוקטור מצב קוונטי
בודד אלא אם קורה משהו טריוויאלי כמו שכל וקטורי המצב הקוונטיים שקולים עד כדי פאזה גלובלית או שכל ההסתברויות
חוץ מאחת הן אפס לא נקבל מצב קוונטי טהור מתהליך כזה אלא נקבל מה שנקרא
מצב קוונטי מעורב שבו יש אי-ודאות מובנית כלשהי בואו נסתכל על דוגמה
פשוטה נניח שיש לנו qubit ובהסתברות חצי ה-qubit מוכן במצב אפס ואחרת
הוא מוכן במצב פלוס הנה מטריצת הצפיפות שנקבל על ידי ממוצע כפי שתיארתי
אנחנו מחשבים את מטריצות הצפיפות המתאימות לשני המצבים האפשריים מכפילים בהסתברויות המתאימות ומחברים את
התוצאות מה שנקבל הוא אכן מטריצת צפיפות היא הרמיטית העקבה שלה שווה לאחד
ואם תחשבו את הערכים העצמיים של המטריצה הזו תקבלו שני מספרים ממשיים חיוביים והם במקרה שני מספרים שכנראה כבר אמורים להיות מוכרים
לכם עד עכשיו קוסינוס בריבוע של פי חלקי 8 וסינוס בריבוע של פי חלקי 8 או בערך 0.85 ו-
0.15 אין ייצוג של וקטור מצב קוונטי בודד למצב הזה הוא לא מצב טהור בשלב הבא נסתכל על
מטריצת צפיפות מסוימת שמייצגת מצב קוונטי של qubit בודד שנקרא המצב המעורב
לחלוטין המצב הזה עולה לעיתים קרובות אז טוב שיש לו שם וזו גם דוגמה טובה כי היא
ממחישה תכונה חשובה של מטריצות צפיפות יש למעשה מצב מעורב לחלוטין מוגדר באופן אנלוגי לכל
מערכת אבל לעכשיו נתמקד במצב הזה עבור qubit בודד רק כדי לשמור על דברים
פשוטים נניח שאנחנו קובעים באקראי את המצב של qubit להיות או מצב אפס או מצב אחד כל אחד עם
הסתברות של חצי בדומה לביט אקראי אחיד אנחנו יכולים לחשב את ייצוג מטריצת הצפיפות של המצב
הזה בדרך הרגילה לוקחים את הממוצע של שני ייצוגי מטריצת הצפיפות של המצבים הנה איך
שזה נראה בצורת מטריצה ומה שמקבלים זה מטריצת היחידה חלקי
שניים המצב הזה נקרא המצב המעורב לחלוטין והוא בעצם מייצג אי-ודאות מוחלטת או מקסימלית
לגבי qubit בדיוק כמו שוקטור הסתברות אחיד מייצג אי-ודאות מקסימלית בהגדרה
ההסתברותית הקלאסית באופן כללי עבור מערכת שרירותית המצב המעורב לחלוטין הוא ה-
מצב שנקבל על ידי בחירה אחידה של מצב בבסיס הסטנדרטי וייצוג מטריצת הצפיפות יהיה
מטריצת היחידה חלקי הממד או באופן שקול מספר המצבים הקלאסיים של
המערכת בשלב הזה זו רק טרמינולוגיה אבל אם נשנה את ההגדרה קצת נראה תכונה חשובה של
מטריצות צפיפות בפרט בואו נניח שאנחנו משנים את הנוהל ובמקום
מצבי הבסיס הסטנדרטי אפס ואחד נחליף למצבים פלוס ומינוס הפעם מתחילים עם
הביטוי שמוצג על המסך אבל אם נעבור את החשבון נקבל בדיוק את אותה
מטריצת צפיפות זו מטריצת היחידה חלקי שניים אז זה אותו מצב כמו קודם
המצב המעורב לחלוטין זו כמו שאומרים תכונה ולא באג שני הנהלים הם למעשה
שונים אבל אם כל מה שיש לכם הוא ה-qubit שנוצר אין שום דרך פיזית שתוכלו להבחין ביניהם
אפילו לא במובן סטטיסטי למשל אם תבצעו מדידה בבסיס הסטנדרטי על ה-qubit הזה
אחרי שהנוהל הראשון בוצע ברור שתקבלו את התוצאה אפס בהסתברות חצי ואת התוצאה אחד בהסתברות חצי אבל גם תקבלו
בדיוק את אותן הסתברויות תוצאה עבור הנוהל השני ואותו דבר נכון לכל מבחן אחר שאולי
תמציאו בהנחה שאתם בודקים רק את ה-qubit עצמו באופן כללי מטריצות צפיפות לא מתארות איך מערכת
הוכנה הן רק אומרות לכם מה יקרה אם תעשו דברים למערכת הזו מעכשיו והלאה בין אם זה ביצוע
פעולות או מדידות ולמעשה מטריצות צפיפות מושלמות בהקשר
הזה אם שתי חלופות שונות מובילות לאותה מטריצת צפיפות אי אפשר להבחין ביניהן אפילו
סטטיסטית אבל אם שתי מטריצות הצפיפות שונות אז תהיה דרך כלשהי להבחין ביניהן לא
בהכרח באופן חד-משמעי אבל במובן סטטיסטי כשמשתמשים בניסוח הכללי של מידע
קוונטי מידע קלאסי למעשה צומח כמקרה פרטי ועכשיו אסביר איך זה
עובד באופן ספציפי נראה איך מצבים הסתברותיים יכולים להיות מיוצגים על ידי מטריצות
צפיפות בואו נתחיל עם מצבים קלאסיים נתחיל עם דוגמה
פשוטה הנה ייצוגי מטריצת הצפיפות של מצבי הבסיס הסטנדרטי אפס ואחד של
qubit אנחנו מקשרים את המצבים האלה עם המצבים הקלאסיים 0 ו-1 ולכן אנחנו יכולים לחשוב על מטריצות הצפיפות האלה כ-
מייצגות את המצבים האלה זה מאוד פשוט ואנחנו יכולים בקלות להכליל את
הדוגמה אם יש לנו מערכת שקבוצת המצבים הקלאסיים שלה היא סיגמא אז מצב קלאסי a מיוצג על ידי או
משויך למטריצת הצפיפות קט a בראa למטריצה הזו יש ערך אחד בודד ב-
איבר האלכסון שהשורה והעמודה שלו מתאימים למצב הקלאסי a וכל איבר אחר הוא
אפס מצבים הסתברותיים מיוצגים על ידי צירופים קמורים של מטריצות מהצורה הזו מה שטבעי
בהתחשב במה שאנחנו יודעים על מטריצות צפיפות ואיך הן עובדות ובפרט שצירופים קמורים של מטריצות צפיפות מייצגים בחירות אקראיות או
הסתברותיות של מצבים קוונטיים למשל בואו נניח שיש
לנו מערכת X שקבוצת המצבים הקלאסיים שלה כוללת את המספרים השלמים 0 עד n מינוס אחד עבור מספר שלם חיובי כלשהו n
כמובן שכמעט ולא מאבדים כלליות בהנחה שקבוצת המצבים הקלאסיים שלנו נראית ככה אם הייתה לנו
קבוצת מצבים קלאסיים אחרת אפשר פשוט לשנות שמות למצבים הקלאסיים בצורה הזו ולעיתים קרובות די נוח לעשות את ההנחה שקבוצות
המצבים הקלאסיים שלנו נראות ככה בעיקר כי זה מקל על כתיבת דברים באופן מפורש באמצעות
וקטורים ומטריצות בהנחה שיש לנו מצב הסתברותי של המערכת X
שמיוצג על ידי וקטור הסתברות בדרך הרגילה אפשר לשייך את המצב ההסתברותי הזה למטריצת
צפיפות כפי שמוצג על המסך לוקחים את הממוצע המשוקלל של מטריצות הצפיפות המתאימות ל-
המצבים הקלאסיים השונים ומה שמקבלים הוא מטריצת צפיפות אלכסונית בפרט אנחנו רואים את ההסתברויות
לאורך האלכסון של המטריצה הזו וכל איבר אחר שווה לאפס כמובן שזו מטריצת צפיפות
אנחנו מצפים שזה יהיה נכון אבל אפשר גם לנמק את זה ישירות זו מטריצה הרמיטית העקבה
שלה שווה לאחד כי ההסתברויות מסתכמות לאחד ובמקרה של מטריצה אלכסונית הערכים העצמיים הם איברי האלכסון
והם כולם אי-שליליים כי הם הסתברויות גם שימו לב שכל
מטריצת צפיפות אלכסונית כלומר כזו שהאיברים שמחוץ לאלכסון שלה כולם אפס חייבת להיראות ככה אז בקיצור
מצבים הסתברותיים יכולים להיות משויכים למטריצות צפיפות אלכסוניות שימו לב דרך אגב שזה עקבי עם
הפרשנות הלא פורמלית של איברי מטריצות צפיפות שהזכרתי בתחילת השיעור בפרט שום דבר לא נמצא ב-
סופרפוזיציה קוונטית כאן זה בעצם רק אקראיות קלאסית ובהתאם כל האיברים שמחוץ לאלכסון
הם אפס מוקדם יותר בסדרה הזו דנו במשפט הספקטרלי ועשינו את זה
באופן ספציפי עבור מטריצות יוניטריות בהקשר של הערכת פאזה המשפט הספקטרלי הוא יותר
כללי מזה אבל כלומר הוא אומר לנו משהו על סוג רחב יותר של מטריצות ולא רק מטריצות יוניטריות
ובפרט הוא חל על סוג מטריצות שנקרא מטריצות נורמליות שכוללות את כל המטריצות ההרמיטיות וגם את
המטריצות היוניטריות מה שנעשה עכשיו הוא להסתכל על ניסוח אחר של המשפט הזה הפעם נתמקד רק ב-
מטריצות חיוביות למחצה ואז נראה שהוא אומר לנו משהו מאוד מעניין וקריטי חשוב על מטריצות
צפיפות נניח ש-P היא מטריצה חיובית למחצה כלשהי אז זה כולל כל מטריצת צפיפות וגם כל
מטריצה חיובית למחצה שלא במקרה יש לה עקבה השווה לאחד P היא חיובית למחצה אז היא חייבת
להיות ריבועית או במילים אחרות n על n עבור בחירה כלשהי של n ונצטרך להתייחס למספר n הזה אז תנו ל-n להיות
נבחר בהתאם או דרך אחרת לומר את כל זה היא נניח ש-P היא n על n מה שהמשפט אומר לנו במקרה הזה הוא
שחייבים להיות בסיס אורתונורמלי של וקטורים שנקרא להם פסאי 0 עד פסאי n מינוס אחד יחד עם מספרים ממשיים אי-שליליים
למבדא 0 עד למבדא n מינוס אחד כך ש-P יכול להיות מבוטא כפי שמוצג
כאן על המסך במילים אם נכפיל כל למבדא k בקט פסאי k כפול בראסאי k ואז
נסכום על כל k מ-0 עד n מינוס אחד נקבל את P זה נקרא פירוק
ספקטרלי של P כל למבדא k הוא בהכרח ערך עצמי של P וכל פסאי k הוא וקטור עצמי יחידתי של P
המתאים לאותו ערך עצמי אם תסתכלו אחורה על שיעור 7 על הערכת פאזה תמצאו משפט דומה
עבור מטריצות יוניטריות שם הערכים העצמיים הם מספרים מרוכבים על מעגל היחידה ולא מספרים ממשיים אי-שליליים
אבל חוץ מזה זה אותו רעיון ואלה באמת רק שני מקרים פרטיים של משפט כללי יותר שנקרא
המשפט הספקטרלי הוא לא עובד לכל מטריצה צריך שהמטריצה תתחלף עם
השחלוף הצמוד שלה וזה מה שזה אומר שמטריצה היא נורמלית אבל למעשה תמיד יש לנו
את זה גם עבור מטריצות יוניטריות וגם עבור מטריצות חיוביות למחצה ועבור מטריצות הרמיטיות באופן כללי יותר שבהן
תמיד יהיו ערכים עצמיים ממשיים אבל לא בהכרח אי-שליליים אז זה היה ניסוח של
המשפט הספקטרלי רק עבור מטריצות חיוביות למחצה ועכשיו בואו נראה מה הוא אומר לנו על מטריצות
צפיפות מה שהוא אומר לנו הוא שעבור מטריצת צפיפות n על n שרירותית תמיד אפשר לבטא את המטריצה כצירוף קמור
של n מצבים טהורים ויתרה מכך אפשר לקחת את אותם n מצבים טהורים להיות
אורתוגונליים זה נובע די ישירות מהמשפט יחד עם עובדה בסיסית מאלגברה לינארית שהיא ש-
סכום הערכים העצמיים של כל מטריצה תמיד שווה לעקבה של אותה מטריצה במילים אחרות כל מה שאנחנו באמת
עושים כאן הוא לשנות שמות לערכים העצמיים ל-p0 עד pn מינוס אחד ואז להבחין שכשעושים את זה ו-
אוספים את הערכים העצמיים האלה לוקטור n-ממדי בהכרח מקבלים וקטור הסתברות כי כולם חייבים להיות אי-שליליים והסכום שלהם שווה ל-
העקבה של רו שהיא אחד כי רו היא מטריצת צפיפות אז זה די פשוט אבל זה
באמת מהותי למדי מבחינה רעיונית מה שזה אומר לנו הוא שכל מטריצת צפיפות לא
משנה כמה מסובכת היא אולי נראית יכולה לנבוע מבחירה ראשונית של בסיס אורתונורמלי של כל מערכת
שעליה אנחנו מדברים ואז בחירה אקראית של מצב קוונטי מהבסיס הזה לפי בחירה כלשהי של ההסתברויות
אם זה לא מיד ברור על פני השטח למה זה מעניין או חשוב זה בסדר אבל אנחנו כן משתמשים בעובדה
הזו לעיתים קרובות מאוד כשחושבים על מטריצות צפיפות ולמעשה לבטא מטריצת צפיפות נתונה
בצורה הזו זה לעיתים קרובות הדבר הראשון שאנחנו עושים כשרוצים להבין אותה
יותר טוב הנה דוגמה נזכיר את מטריצת הצפיפות שהגענו אליה קודם כשבחרנו באקראי בין
מצב אפס למצב פלוס כל אחד בהסתברות חצי שכפי שחישבנו יש לה מטריצת צפיפות שנראית
ככה מצב אפס ומצב פלוס הם לא אורתוגונליים אז זה לא פירוק
ספקטרלי אבל אם נחשב אחד מה שאפשר לעשות עם מחשב או ביד במקרה כזה אז מה שנקבל
הוא הביטוי הזה של מטריצת הצפיפות שלנו שבו הערכים העצמיים הם המספרים שממשיכים להופיע ו-
שבו הוקטורים העצמיים המתאימים יכולים להיבחר כפי שמוצג כאן למטה על המסך ושוב ראינו את הוקטורים האלה קודם למשל בהקשר
של משחק CHSH בשיעור ארבע אז זה מעניין לפי
הביטוי המקורי המצב הזה הוא מה שמקבלים על ידי בחירה אחידה בין שני מצבים מצב אפס ו-
מצב פלוס אבל למעשה מקבלים בדיוק את אותה מטריצת צפיפות על ידי בחירה אקראית בין שני מצבים
טהורים אבל עם הטיה מאוד מאוד חזקה לאחד מהם בערך 85% לראשון ורק בערך 15% ל-
שני אז במובן מסוים יש בעצם פחות אקראיות טמונה במצב ממה שאולי נראה במקור
יש דרך גיאומטרית מאוד יפה לחשוב על ולדמיין מצבים קוונטיים של qubit בודד שנקראת
כדור Bloch היא עובדת רק עבור qubit בודד עבור מערכות עם שלושה
מצבים קלאסיים או יותר כולל שני qubits או יותר יחד היא לא עובדת יותר אז היא די מוגבלת אבל
בכל זאת זו דרך מצוינת לחשוב על המצבים של qubit בודד היא הייתה יכולה להיות מוצגת עוד
בשיעור הראשון של הסדרה על מערכות בודדות אבל היא לא באמת חיונית להבנת איך מידע קוונטי עובד ויש לה גם
חיבור מאוד יפה עם מטריצות צפיפות אז היא משתלבת באופן טבעי בשיעור הזה ולמעשה אני הולך להסביר
אותה בצורה קצת שונה מאיך שהיא בדרך כלל מוסברת על ידי שימוש במטריצות צפיפות כדי למעשה
לגזור אותה אז אם אתם כבר מכירים את כדור Bloch ההסבר הזה אולי קצת שונה מהדרך
שבה למדתם עליה לראשונה אבל בסופו של דבר הוא כמובן אמור להיות שקול נתחיל בלחשוב על
המצבים הטהורים האפשריים של qubit קודם כפי שמיוצגים על ידי וקטורי מצב
קוונטיים עד כדי פאזה גלובלית כל וקטור מצב קוונטי של qubit יכול להיות מבוטא כפי
שמוצג כאן על המסך ליתר דיוק יש לנו שני מספרים ממשיים תטא ופי ונחשוב
על שני המספרים האלה כזוויות מבוטאות ברדיאנים המספר הראשון תטא הוא בין 0 לפי או באופן שקול זו
זווית בין 0 ל-180 מעלות והמספר השני פי הוא בין 0 ל-2 פי כולל 0 אבל לא 2
פי אז זו כל זווית בין 0 ל-360 מעלות האיבר אפס של הוקטור שלנו הוא
קוסינוס של תטא חלקי 2 אז זה מספר ממשי בין 0 ל-1 ובפרט הוא בהכרח אי-שלילי
והאיבר אחד של הוקטור שלנו הוא e בחזקת i כפול פי כפול סינוס של תטא חלקי 2 וזה יכול
להיות כל מספר מרוכב על או בתוך מעגל היחידה המרוכב זה תמיד וקטור יחידה או
במילים אחרות זה וקטור מצב קוונטי תקף ולכל וקטור מצב קוונטי של qubit נתון תמיד אפשר למצוא
וקטור בצורה הזו ששקול לאותו וקטור עד כדי פאזה גלובלית בפרט תמיד אפשר
להכפיל את הוקטור הנתון בפאזה גלובלית כדי שהאיבר אפס יהיה מספר ממשי אי-שלילי לבחור כל
תטא שעובד כדי לתת לנו את האיבר הזה ואז לבחור פי כדי להתאים לאיבר אחד הגודל של איבר אחד
תמיד בהכרח יתאים לסינוס של תטא חלקי שניים מההנחה שהתחלנו עם וקטור
יחידה עכשיו זה לא ממש המצב שתטא ופי נקבעים באופן יחיד על ידי כל וקטור מצב קוונטי שהתחלנו
ממנו אבל זה כמעט כך תמיד יהיה ערך יחיד של תטא בין אפס לפי שעובד
ובדרך כלל יש ערך יחיד של פי שעובד אבל בשני מקרים מיוחדים זה לא נכון בפרט אם התחלנו עם
מצב בסיס סטנדרטי אז תטא יהיה או אפס או פי ובשני המקרים לא באמת משנה מה פי הוא הוא
לגמרי לא רלוונטי כשתטא הוא אפס הקוסינוס של תטא חלקי 2 הוא 1 והסינוס של תטא חלקי 2
הוא אפס אז אנחנו מכפילים e בחזקת i כפול פי באפס אז זה לא משנה מה פי הוא
ואם תטא הוא פי אז הפעם הקוסינוס הוא אפס והסינוס הוא אחד אז יש לנו e בחזקת i כפול פי כפול קט1 אבל ה-
וקטורים האלה כולם שקולים עד כדי פאזה גלובלית אז שוב לא משנה מה פי הוא אבל אם תטא נמצא ממש
בין אפס לפי אז תמיד יהיה ערך יחיד של פי שעובד ודרך אגב הניוון
האפשרי הזה בערך של פי עבור שני המקרים המיוחדים יהיה הגיוני לחלוטין כשנראה את התמונה הגיאומטרית
עוד קצת עכשיו בואו נחשב את מטריצת הצפיפות המשויכת לוקטור מצב בצורה שזה עתה
זיהינו אז זה יהיה מצב טהור של qubit כדי לעשות את זה נכפיל את הוקטור
בשחלוף הצמוד שלו כרגיל ועל המסך יש ביטוי של המטריצה שנקבל על ידי חישוב
השחלוף הצמוד וביצוע הכפל עכשיו בדיוק כמו כל מטריצה 2 על
2 יש דרך יחידה לקבל את המטריצה הזו על ידי לקיחת צירוף לינארי של מטריצות Pauli
כולל מטריצת היחידה בפרט אפשר לקבל את המטריצה הזו על ידי בחירת המקדמים של
מטריצות Pauli כפי שמוצג כאן על המסך אנחנו שמים 2 במכנה כי זה הולך לגרום
לכל הדברים לצאת יפה שום דבר לא מכריח אותנו לעשות את זה אבל אנחנו יכולים וזה הולך להיות מועיל לעשות את זה אבל מלבד
הבחירה הקוסמטית הזו אין כאן חופש זו הדרך היחידה לקבל את המטריצה הזו על ידי צירוף לינארי של מטריצות Pauli וזה
כי מטריצות Pauli כולל מטריצת היחידה הן בסיס למרחב הוקטורי של כל המטריצות 2 על 2 דרך אחת
לבדוק את נכונות הביטוי הזה היא להשתמש בכמה זהויות טריגונומטריות בסיסיות ובפרט אם אזוז מהדרך
לרגע הנה כמה זהויות שיעשו את העבודה אז אם אתם רוצים עצרו את הסרטון או
צלמו מסך ותנסו להגיע מהביטוי השני של מטריצת הצפיפות למטה מהראשון אז לסיכום כל מצב טהור של
qubit מבוטא כמטריצת צפיפות יכול להיכתב כצירוף לינארי של מטריצות Pauli כפי שמוצג על
המסך עבור תטא בין 0 לפי ופי בין 0 ל-2 פי שימו לב שיש לנו בדיוק את אותו
ניוון כמו קודם שהוא שפי לא רלוונטי כשתטא הוא או אפס או פי והפעם אפשר ממש
לראות את זה יותר בבירור כי הסינוס של תטא הוא אפס בשני המקרים האלה ואחרת הוא לא שווה לו לציין
שבנוסחה הזו יש לנו תטא מופיע כארגומנט לפונקציות סינוס וקוסינוס ולא תטא חלקי 2 כמו בוקטור המצב הקוונטי
המקורי וזה בגלל שהשתמשנו בזהויות הטריגונומטריות האלה שלוש הראשונות מביניהן הן בעצם
סידורים מחדש של מה שנקרא נוסחאות הזווית הכפולה אז הזווית למעשה מוכפלת ועכשיו סוף סוף אנחנו מוכנים ל-
דבר על כדור Bloch עצמו בואו נתמקד בשלושת המקדמים של מטריצות Pauli שהן לא
מטריצת היחידה במונה של הביטוי של מטריצת הצפיפות שלנו אז אנחנו מתעלמים מה-2 ב-
מכנה אנחנו גם מתעלמים ממטריצת היחידה כי המקדם עליה אף פעם לא משתנה זה קורה כי
המקדם הזה נקבע על ידי העקבה של כל מטריצה שאנחנו מבטאים ומטריצות צפיפות תמיד יש להן עקבה השווה
לאחד עכשיו דמיינו שיש לנו שלושה צירים שמסומנים x y ו-z מכוונים לפי
מה שנקרא כלל יד ימין ונתבונן בנקודה שהקואורדינטות שלה תואמות לשלושת המקדמים ורק להיות ברורים זה
מרחב תלת-ממדי רגיל שאנחנו מדברים עליו שבו הקואורדינטות הן תמיד מספרים ממשיים
קואורדינטת x מתאימה למקדם של מטריצת Pauli סיגמא X במונה של הביטוי שלנו שתמיד הוא מספר ממשי כי מטריצות
צפיפות הן הרמיטיות ובאופן דומה עבור Y ו-Z מה שנמצא הוא שהנקודה הזו
שנקבל היא תמיד על ספירת היחידה או במילים אחרות הספירה עם רדיוס השווה ל-
אחד ובפרט זו הנקודה שנקבל אם נתחיל מהנקודה שבה ציר z החיובי חוצה את הספירה
שאפשר לחשוב עליה כקוטב הצפוני נסובב למטה לכיוון ציר x החיובי בזווית של תטא ואז
נסובב לכיוון ציר y החיובי או במילים אחרות מזרחה בזווית של פי בהקשר הזה הזווית תטא
נקראת הזווית הפולרית מה שקל לזכור כי היא מתחילה מהקוטב ופי נקראת הזווית
האזימוטלית ויחד שתי הזוויות האלה מייצגות קואורדינטות כדוריות לנקודות על ספירת היחידה ואם
רוצים אפשר גם לאפשר לרדיוס להשתנות כדי לייצג נקודות שרירותיות במרחב תלת-ממדי אבל כאן אנחנו מתמקדים בנקודות על
ספירת היחידה שבה הרדיוס שווה לאחד אפשר גם לחשוב על תטא כמייצג קו רוחב חוץ מזה שאנחנו הולכים
מ-0 ל-180 מעלות מהקוטב הצפוני לקוטב הדרומי ולא פלוס מינוס 90 מעלות מקו המשווה ופי מייצג
קו אורך שבו אנחנו בעצם מגדירים את קו האורך הראשי כקו האורך שחוצה את ציר
x החיובי אם אתם כמוני דרך אגב ויש לכם קושי לזכור מה זה קו רוחב ומה זה קו אורך אולי יעזור לזכור
שקו אורך מתאים לרווח שהוא ארוך יותר 2 פי לעומת
פי בכל מקרה הנקודה שנקבל על ספירת היחידה מוקטור המצב הקוונטי של ה-qubit פסאי על ידי חשיבה על קואורדינטות בצורה
הזו היא ייצוג כדור Bloch של המצב הקוונטי המתאים לפסאי וכשחושבים על כל
ספירת היחידה התלת-ממדית בצורה הזו מקבלים את כדור Bloch גיאומטרית זה רק ספירת
יחידה במרחב תלת-ממדי רגיל אבל למעשה זו הגיאומטריה של מצבי
qubit יש כאן התאמה חד-חד-ערכית מושלמת כל מצב טהור של qubit מתאים לנקודה יחידה על
הספירה וכל נקודה על הספירה מייצגת מצב qubit יחיד עד כדי פאזה גלובלית כשעובדים עם
וקטורי מצב קוונטיים ההתאמה הזו ידועה גם בשמות אחרים דרך אגב היא נקראת לפעמים גם ספירת Poincare
למשל אבל בהקשר של מידע קוונטי מתייחסים אליה בדרך כלל ככדור Bloch שימו לב שעכשיו אפשר לראות את
הניוון בזווית פי די בבירור כי לקו אורך אין משמעות בקטבים הצפוני והדרומי אבל מלבד
הקטבים לכל נקודה על כדור הארץ יש קואורדינטות ייחודיות במונחים של קו רוחב וקו אורך ואותו דבר קורה כאן אז ככה
כדור Bloch עובד באופן כללי עכשיו בואו נסתכל על כמה דוגמאות ספציפיות של מצבי qubit ו-
איפה הם נמצאים על כדור Bloch נתחיל עם הבסיס הסטנדרטי אלה הנקודות שנקבל
כשהזווית הפולרית תטא היא אפס עבור מצב אפס ופי עבור מצב אחד אלה שני המקרים שבהם
הזווית האזימוטלית פי לא רלוונטית כפי שכבר דנתי אפשר גם לבטא את מטריצות הצפיפות המתאימות כצירופים
לינאריים של מטריצות Pauli בכל דרך אנחנו מסיקים ששני המצבים האלה מתאימים לקוטב הצפוני ול-
קוטב הדרומי של כדור Bloch מצב אפס נמצא למעלה ומצב אחד נמצא ל-
מטה בשלב הבא בואו נמצא את מצבי פלוס ומינוס על כדור Bloch שוב אפשר לחשוב על
וקטורי מצב קוונטיים או מטריצות צפיפות עבור וקטורי מצב קוונטיים הפעם הזווית הפולרית תטא צריכה להיות פי
חלקי 2 כדי שהאיבר אפס יהיה 1 חלקי שורש 2 הזווית האזימוטלית פי צריכה להיות אפס
עבור מצב פלוס כי האיבר אחד הוא חיובי עבור מצב פלוס והיא צריכה להיות פי או 180 מעלות עבור מצב מינוס
כי האיבר הזה שלילי במקרה הזה אז שתי הנקודות האלה נמצאות על
קו המשווה של כדור Bloch מצב פלוס נמצא שם שציר x החיובי חוצה את הספירה ומצב מינוס נמצא בצד הנגדי שם ש-
ציר x השלילי חוצה את הספירה באופן שקול אפשר גם לראות מהביטויים של מטריצות Pauli עבור
מטריצות הצפיפות המתאימות שקואורדינטות Y ו-Z הן שתיהן אפס בעוד שקואורדינטות x הן חיובי ושלילי
1 דוגמה נוספת היא בסיס פלוס i מינוס i שדומה לבסיס פלוס מינוס חוץ מזה שגם מכפילים את
איבר אחד ב-i היחידה המדומה ראינו את מצב פלוס i מוקדם יותר בשיעור ומצב מינוס i מוגדר
בצורה אנלוגית הזווית הפולרית תטא היא אותו דבר כמו שהייתה עבור מצבי פלוס ומינוס פי
חלקי 2 והפעם צריך לבחור את הזווית האזימוטלית פי כדי שנקבל i ומינוס i ולא 1 ומינוס 1
ופי חלקי 2 ו-3 פי חלקי 2 הן הבחירות הנכונות כדי שזה יקרה שוב אפשר גם להסתכל על
תיאורי מטריצת הצפיפות של המצבים האלה והדברים די דומים לשתי הדוגמאות הקודמות חוץ מזה שהפעם מטריצת Pauli Y במקום
Z או X אז על כדור Bloch שני המצבים האלה נמצאים היכן שציר y
חוצה את הספירה ואם ננקה קצת אפשר לראות יותר בבירור איך ששת המצבים שזה עתה דנו בהם
מתייחסים זה לזה עבור עוד דוגמה אחת או באמת סוג של דוגמאות בואו ניקח את
וקטורי המצב הקוונטיים של qubit שעלו קודם ובשיעור ארבע שבהם איבר אפס הוא קוסינוס של אלפא עבור מספר ממשי כלשהו אלפא ואיבר
אחד הוא סינוס של אלפא דרך אגב אפשר להגביל את עצמנו לערכים של אלפא בין אפס לפי כי כל
ערך אחר של אלפא ייתן לנו וקטור ששקול עד כדי פאזה גלובלית לאחד שבו אלפא נמצא בטווח
הזה אם נחשב את מטריצות הצפיפות המשויכות למצבים האלה מבוטאות כצירופים לינאריים של מטריצות Pauli
נקבל את הביטוי שמוצג כאן על המסך החישוב הזה לא מוצג כאן אבל זה מה שאתם אמורים
לקבל אם תעברו אותו ומה שנמצא הוא שהמצבים האלה יוצרים מה שנקרא מעגל גדול שעובר
דרך הקטבים באופן ספציפי מתחילים מהקוטב הצפוני כשאלפא הוא אפס יורדים דרך קו האורך הראשי ו-
מגיעים לקוטב הדרומי כשאלפא הוא פי חלקי 2 ואז חוזרים לקוטב הצפוני בצד הנגדי של הספירה כשאלפא נע מפי חלקי 2 ל-
פי וכל זה הגיוני כי ראשית אלה וקטורים ממשיים אז החלק המדומה תמיד אפס ושנית
הזווית אלפא למעשה מוכפלת על כדור Bloch ושוב אפשר להסביר את זה על ידי השימוש
בנוסחאות הזווית הכפולה ראינו שכדור Bloch מספק ייצוג גיאומטרי מאוד יפה למצבים הטהורים של
qubit שבו כל נקודה על הספירה מתאימה למצב טהור יחיד של qubit ולהיפך
כשמתייחסים לכדור Bloch אנחנו מדברים על כל הנקודות על כדור Bloch וגם הנקודות
שבתוכו נקודות בפנים של כדור Bloch גם מתאימות למצבי qubit
ספציפית מצבים שהם לא מצבים טהורים אז במילים אחרות אלה מצבי qubit שיכולים להיות מיוצגים על ידי מטריצות צפיפות אבל לא על ידי וקטורי מצב
קוונטיים היבט יסודי של כדור Bloch והדרך שבה הנקודות הפנימיות מייצגות מצבים לא טהורים הוא ש-
צירופים קמורים של נקודות בתוך כדור Bloch מתאימים לצירופים קמורים של מטריצות צפיפות
אינטואיטיבית זה אומר שהגיאומטריה ממשיכה לעבוד בצורה מושלמת גם בתוך כדור
Bloch בואו נסתכל על כמה דוגמאות נתחיל עם נקודת המרכז של כדור Bloch שמייצגת את
המצב המעורב לחלוטין המצב המעורב לחלוטין מתקבל על ידי ממוצע מצבי אפס ואחד מה שעקבי עם העובדה
שמרכז הספירה הוא בדיוק באמצע בין הקוטב הצפוני לקוטב הדרומי ולמעשה הוא באמצע בין כל שתי נקודות אנטיפודליות כמו
מצבי פלוס ומינוס ומצבי פלוס i ומינוס i נקודות אנטיפודליות בכדור Bloch תמיד מתאימות ל-
מצבים טהורים אורתוגונליים ומה שזה חושף או משקף הוא שתמיד אפשר לכתוב את המצב המעורב לחלוטין
כממוצע בין כל שני מצבי qubit טהורים אורתוגונליים דרך נוספת לראות את זה היא ל-
חשוב על ייצוג מטריצות Pauli של המצב המעורב לחלוטין כדי שזה יעבוד צריך לקבוע
את המקדמים על כל שלוש מטריצות Pauli שאינן היחידה להיות אפס ולכן הנקודה המתאימה בתוך
כדור Bloch היא ממש במרכז בראשית ודרך אגב לחשוב על ייצוגי מטריצות Pauli של מטריצות
צפיפות ככה למעשה מבהיר די טוב שצירופים קמורים של נקודות בכדור Bloch מתאימים לצירופים קמורים
של מטריצות צפיפות אם לוקחים ממוצע או ממוצע משוקלל של מטריצות צפיפות ו-
מבטאים הכל במונחים של צירופים לינאריים של מטריצות Pauli אז כמובן שפשוט ממצעים את הנקודות המתאימות כי הכל
לינארי בשלושת המקדמים האלה לעוד דוגמה אחת בואו ניקח את הממוצע של מצב אפס
ומצב פלוס שראינו מוקדם יותר בשיעור חישבנו את ייצוג מטריצת הצפיפות שמוצג על
המסך ויש לנו שהנקודה נמצאת בפנים של כדור Bloch באמצע בין מצב אפס למצב
פלוס גם ראינו שאפשר לבטא את מטריצת הצפיפות הזו בצורה אחרת על סמך הפירוק הספקטרלי שלה ו-
שוב זה עקבי עם הדיאגרמה והדוגמאות הקודמות וזה מסיים את
הדיון על כדור Bloch וכדור Bloch אנשים שואלים לעיתים קרובות אם יש כדור Bloch עבור מערכות עם
שלושה מצבים קלאסיים או יותר והתשובה המאכזבת היא לא ממש תמיד אפשר לחשוב על
המצבים הקוונטיים של מערכת במונחים גיאומטריים בדומה לכדור Bloch ונקבל גוף קמור במרחב וקטורי
ממשי אבל אם יש לנו שלושה מצבים קלאסיים או יותר הוא לא יהיה כדורי למשל אם יש
בדיוק שלושה מצבים קלאסיים או quטריט בקיצור נקבל גוף קמור במרחב תמני-
ממדי אבל הנקודות הקיצוניות של הגוף הזה שמתאימות למצבים הקוונטיים הטהורים של quטריט יהיו רק
ארבע-ממדיות אם אתם מסוגלים לדמיין לקיחת יריעה ארבע-ממדית במרחב תמני-ממדי ואיכשהו לעטוף אותה בצלופן כדי לקבל גוף קמור
ואתם מוצאים שזו דרך מועילה לחשוב על quטריטים אז כל הכבוד לכם אני מניח זה מעניין ל-
חשוב על זה אבל זה לא כדור זה יותר מסובך מזה בחלק האחרון של השיעור נדון בקצרה ב-
איך מטריצות צפיפות עובדות עבור מערכות מרובות מטריצות צפיפות יכולות לייצג מצבים של מערכות מרובות וזה
עובד באופן אנלוגי לחלוטין לוקטורי מצב קוונטיים בפרט בדיוק כמו שיש לנו בניסוח המפושט של מידע
קוונטי אנחנו יכולים לראות מערכות מרובות יחד כאילו הן מערכות מורכבות
בודדות הפעם גם השורות וגם העמודות של מטריצות צפיפות שמייצגות מצבים של מערכות מרובות
מועמדות בהתאמה עם המכפלה הקרטזית של קבוצות המצבים הקלאסיים של המערכות הבודדות למשל אפשר לשקול
ייצוגי מטריצת צפיפות של ארבעת מצבי Bell שנקבלים בדיוק כפי שעשינו עבור וקטורי מצב
קוונטיים אחרים מוקדם יותר בשיעור על ידי הכפלת וקטורי מצב בשחלופים הצמודים שלהם והתוצאות מוצגות כאן על
המסך בעצם אין כאן שום דבר חדש ברמה הרעיונית אם כי נראה עוד רגע שיש כמה
דברים חדשים שאפשר לעשות עם מטריצות צפיפות עבור מערכות מרובות המושגים של עצמאות ו-
קורלציות עוברים מוקטורי מצב קוונטיים למטריצות צפיפות ובפרט אנחנו מוצאים שמכפלות טנזוריות
של מטריצות צפיפות מייצגות עצמאות בין מערכות אנחנו משתמשים באותה טרמינולוגיה
שהשתמשנו בה עבור וקטורי מצב קוונטיים למשל אם יש לנו מערכת X שמוכנה במצב רו ומערכת Y
שמוכנה באופן בלתי תלוי במצב סיגמא אז המצב של הזוג XY יחד נתון על ידי המכפלה הטנזורית
של רו וסיגמא אנחנו קוראים לזה מצב מכפלה וזה מוכלל בצורה טבעית ליותר משתי
מערכות מטריצות צפיפות שלא ניתן לבטא כמצבי מכפלה מייצגות קורלציות בין מערכות וה-
חלק הזה דומה לוקטורי מצב קוונטיים אבל כפי שמתברר יש סוגים שונים של קורלציות שיכולים לצוץ כשמשתמשים במטריצות צפיפות אפילו עבור
שתי מערכות בלבד לעומת זאת יש באמת רק סוג אחד של קורלציה שיכול להיות לוקטורי מצב קוונטיים ו-
זו שזירה כדי לומר את זה אחרת קורלציה ושזירה הן מילים נרדפות עבור וקטורי מצב קוונטיים אבל
זה לא נכון עבור מטריצות צפיפות כאן הדברים יותר מעניינים למשל אפשר לתאר
מצבים קלאסיים מתואמים עם מטריצות צפיפות הנה דוגמה של מטריצת צפיפות שמייצגת ביט אקראי קלאסי
משותף בין Alice ו-Bob תמיד יש להם אותו מצב קלאסי אפס או אחד וההסתברות היא
חצי לכל אחת מהאפשרויות זה לא מצב שזור שזירה היא לא-קלאסית אבל
זה כן מצב מתואם דוגמה נוספת קשורה למושג של אנסמבל של מצבים קוונטיים
שאפשר לחשוב עליו כהתפלגות הסתברות על קבוצה סופית של מצבים קוונטיים בפרט בואו נדמיין שיש
לנו M מטריצות צפיפות רו אפס עד רו M מינוס אחד שכולן מייצגות מצבים אפשריים של מערכת מסוימת
יחד עם הסתברות לשלוף כל אחת אם רצינו יכולנו לחשב את הממוצע המשוקלל של מטריצות
הצפיפות האלה על ידי לקיחת צירוף קמור שלהן אבל זה לא היה באמת אומר לנו מה המצבים הבודדים היו או מה
ההסתברויות היו מה שכן אפשר לעשות ולפעמים זה מאוד שימושי הוא לשקול מטריצת
צפיפות בצורה שמוצגת כאן על המסך זה מצב של שתי מערכות שבו למערכת הראשונה יש מצב קלאסי אחד
לכל אחת מהחלופות ולוקחים ממוצע משוקלל של M מצבי מכפלה שבהם המצב של
המערכת הראשונה הוא תמיד קלאסי ובעצם מסמן איזה מה-M מצבים יש לנו עבור המערכת
השנייה אם לא ברור בדיוק למה נרצה לחשוב על מצבים כאלה זה בסדר זו רק דוגמה של
סוג של קורלציה שבו המערכת הראשונה היא תמיד קלאסית והמערכת השנייה יכולה להיות במצב
קוונטי קטגוריה שלישית של מצבים שאולי מתואמים היא קבוצת מה שנקרא מצבים
ספרביליים במילים פשוטות אלה צירופים קמורים של מצבי מכפלה והם בעצם מייצגים מצבים קוונטיים
שבהם כל הקורלציות בין המערכות הן קורלציות קלאסיות דרך אחת לחשוב על
מצבים כאלה היא שעושים בחירה הסתברותית עבור מספר k ואז מכינים באופן בלתי תלוי שתי
מערכות במצב קוונטי שיכול להיות תלוי בבחירה הזו של k מה שאולי הכי מעניין ב-
מצבים מהצורה הזו הוא שככה אנחנו למעשה מגדירים שזירה במונחים מתמטיים בפרט שזירה
מוגדרת כהיעדר ספרביליות אז אם יש לכם מטריצת צפיפות ולא ניתן לבטא אותה בצורה
כזו אז בהגדרה היא שזורה רמזתי על זה בשיעור ארבע והנה זה ביתר
פירוט דרך אגב יכול להיות מאוד קשה להבין אם מטריצת צפיפות נתונה מייצגת מצב שזור
אפילו בעזרת מחשב מתמטית וחישובית שזירה היא
למעשה די מסובכת הזכרתי בתחילת השיעור שיש דבר מאוד חשוב שאפשר לעשות עם מטריצות צפיפות ו-
זה לתאר את המצבים של חלקים מבודדים של מערכות גם כשהם מתואמים ואולי שזורים עם מערכות
אחרות המונח מצב מצומצם משמש לעיתים קרובות בהקשר הזה וכדוגמה פשוטה נחשב את המצבים
המצומצמים עבור ה-qubits הבודדים שמרכיבים ebit ליתר דיוק נניח ש-
Alice ו-Bob חולקים ebit ל-Alice יש qubit A ל-Bob יש qubit B ויחד שני ה-qubits האלה נמצאים במצב פי
פלוס והשאלה שנתייחס אליה היא מהו המצב של qubit A של Alice ב-
בידוד כמובן אפשר לשאול את אותה שאלה לגבי qubit B של Bob אבל קל לענות על השאלה הזו ברגע שנדע את התשובה ל-
שאלה הזו עכשיו אולי מפתה לומר שאי אפשר לתאר את המצב של qubit A של Alice בבידוד כי הוא
שזור עם qubit B של Bob מה שאולי אוסר עלינו לתאר או אפילו לחשוב על המצב של A ב-
בידוד אבל זה לא נכון נכון שאי אפשר לתאר את המצב של A עם וקטור מצב
קוונטי כי כפי שנראה הוא לא במצב טהור אבל לכל מערכת יש מצב בכל רגע נתון שניתן
לתאר על ידי מטריצת צפיפות בין אם היא שזורה עם מערכת אחרת ובין אם לא כניסוי מחשבתי רק כדי לעזור
לנו לראות מה התשובה לשאלה הזו בואו נניח ש-Bob מחליט לקחת את ה-qubit שלו ולנסוע לכוכבים והוא אף פעם לא נשמע
ממנו שוב אבל דמיינו שאיפשהו בדרך הוא מחליט לבצע מדידה בבסיס הסטנדרטי על
ה-qubit שלו ובכן אנחנו יודעים לחשב את ההסתברויות שהוא יקבל את שתי התוצאות האפשריות ואנחנו גם יודעים מה
המצב של A יהיה לכל תוצאה אפשרית והדברים האלה מסוכמים בטבלה הזו בפרט בהסתברות חצי
A יישאר במצב אפס ובהסתברות חצי A יישאר במצב אחד ולכן כפי שנדון מוקדם יותר ב-
שיעור זה משאיר את A במצב המעורב לחלוטין ולכן זו התשובה
לשאלה שלנו עכשיו אולי תתנגדו ותגידו שזה תלוי בעובדה ש-
Bob החליט למדוד את ה-qubit שלו וההנחה שהוא עושה את זה היא חלק מהסיפור שהוביל אותנו לתשובה הזו אבל
אם Bob נמצא במרחק של שנות אור עד שהוא מודד שום דבר שהוא עושה לא יכול להשפיע על כל
ניסוי ש-Alice אולי תחליט לבצע על ה-qubit שלה אחרת הייתה לנו תקשורת מהירה מ-
אור אז ה-qubit של Alice נמצא במצב המעורב לחלוטין ללא קשר לאם Bob
מודד או לא עלי להבהיר בנקודה הזו שלמושג של מצב מצומצם ולדרך שבה הם מוגדרים אין באמת תלות ביחסות
או באי-האפשרות של תקשורת מהירה מאור זו רק דרך להסביר את זה במונחים שמקווה שהם אינטואיטיביים
במציאות יש הגדרה מתמטית שנראה אותה בהקשר כללי יותר עוד כמה רגעים היא עקבית עם התשובה הזו
ובאופן מקרי גם עם אי-האפשרות של תקשורת מהירה מאור וגם אין שום הגדרה
אחרת שיכולה להיות עקבית עם מידע קוונטי כפי שאנחנו מכירים אותו עכשיו בואו נשקול מצבים מצומצמים באופן
כללי יותר נניח שיש לנו זוג מערכות A ו-B לא בהכרח qubits שיחד נמצאות במצב טהור
שמיוצג על ידי וקטור מצב קוונטי פסאי שוב אנחנו הולכים להתמקד במצב המצומצם של מערכת A ולשם
כך יהיה מועיל לחשוב על המצבים הקלאסיים של מערכת B אז בואו נסמן בגמא את קבוצת
המצבים הקלאסיים של B כפי שדנו קודם למשל בשיעור שתיים של הסדרה
יש אוסף יחיד של וקטורים פי b לכל b בגמא שעבורו הביטוי של פסאי שמוצג על המסך
נכון ובפרט יש נוסחה פשוטה לוקטורים האלה פשוט מכפילים את הוקטור פסאי ב-
מכפלה טנזורית של מטריצת היחידה המתאימה למערכת A עם בראb עבור כל b שמעניין
אותנו מה שאנחנו עושים כאן הוא בעצם מכינים את עצמנו לחשב מה יקרה אם נבצע
מדידה בבסיס הסטנדרטי על B ושוב זה כוסה בשיעור שתיים של
הסדרה נניח שבאמת ביצענו מדידה בבסיס הסטנדרטי על B כל תוצאה אפשרית אז תופיע
בהסתברות השווה לנורמה האוקלידית בריבוע של הוקטור המתאים פי b ובהתניה על קבלת
תוצאה מסוימת b מנרמלים את הוקטור פי b כדי לקבוע את המצב שנוצר של
A בעקבות אותו היגיון כמו בדוגמת ה-ebit מלפני כמה רגעים נקבל את הביטוי שמוצג על
המסך עבור המצב המצומצם של A כמטריצת צפיפות ודרך אגב הנורמה בריבוע במכנה באה מ-
הכפלת הוקטור המנורמל בשחלוף הצמוד שלו אז אנחנו מרימים את הנורמה האוקלידית פעמיים ב-
מכנה הנורמות האוקלידיות בריבוע מתבטלות ונשארים עם ביטוי
די פשוט ולמעשה אם נציב את הנוסחה שלנו עבור פי b שעובדת לכל b נקבל נוסחה למצב המצומצם
של מערכת A במונחים של תיאור מטריצת הצפיפות של המצב הטהור שהתחלנו ממנו כלומר קט פסאי
בראפסאי אז זו הנוסחה שלנו למצב המצומצם של מערכת A בהנחה שהמערכת המורכבת AB התחילה ב-
מצב הטהור פסאי אבל אפשר גם להשתמש בנוסחה באופן כללי יותר בפרט בואו נניח
שהמצב של AB נתון על ידי מטריצת צפיפות כלשהי רו שיכולה להיות בצורה קט פסאי בראפסאי עבור וקטור מצב
קוונטי כלשהו פסאי אבל לא בהכרח נובע בעיקרון מלינאריות שהמצב המצומצם של A
נקבע על ידי אותה נוסחה שהייתה לנו למצבים טהורים חוץ מזה שמציבים כל מטריצת צפיפות רו
שרוצים כסימון מקוצר די נפוץ שמסמנים את המצב המצומצם הזה בכל שם שמשתמשים
למטריצת הצפיפות רו במקרה הזה אבל שמים תחתית שמציינת את המערכת שעליה מתמקדים אז רו עם
תחתית A פירושו המצב המצומצם של A כשהמערכת המורכבת נמצאת במצב רו עליות משמשות גם לפעמים
במקום תחתיות זה בעצם רק העדפה אישית וזה אומר אותו
דבר התמקדנו במערכת A רק לשם פשטות אבל אפשר גם לקבל את המצב המצומצם של מערכת B
באופן אנלוגי אבל כשהנוסחה מותאמת בצורה הטבעית הכל סימטרי כאן אנחנו
בעצם רק מחליפים את התפקידים של A ו-B ובפרט הסכום עובר על המצבים הקלאסיים של A הפעם
ולא של B ובנוסחה שעל המסך אנחנו מניחים שקבוצת המצבים הקלאסיים של A נקראת
סיגמא כל זה מוכלל בצורה די ישירה לשלוש מערכות או יותר למשל אם יש לנו שלוש
מערכות A B ו-C שביחד נמצאות במצב שמתואר על ידי מטריצת הצפיפות רו אז אפשר לקבל את
המצב המצומצם של הזוג AB יחד על ידי הנוסחה שמוצגת כאן וגם את המצב של המערכת השלישית לבד
שהיא הנוסחה השנייה ואפשר לשקול צירופים אחרים ולהכליל את זה לכמה מערכות שרוצים הסכומים תמיד נלקחים על
קבוצות המצבים הקלאסיים של המערכות שמתעלמים מהן והתבנית תמיד אותו דבר עם מטריצת
הצפיפות שהתחלנו ממנה ממולחצת בין המכפלה הטנזורית של מטריצת היחידה ובראות וקטים שמתאימים למצבי בסיס
סטנדרטיים לסיום השיעור אגיד עוד קצת על ההגדרות שזה עתה כיסינו הפעולה על מטריצות
צפיפות שמתארת מצבים מצומצמים יש לה שם והיא נקראת העקבה החלקית עבור שתי מערכות A ו-B
העקבה החלקית על B והעקבה החלקית על A מוגדרות כאן על המסך אלה בדיוק אותן
נוסחאות שראינו לפני כמה רגעים ועכשיו אנחנו פשוט חושבים עליהן כפונקציות של רו ונותנים להן
שמות השמות נראים כמו העקבה חוץ מזה שיש תחתית שאומרת לנו איזו מערכת מוסרים
או במילים אחרות איזו מערכת היא זו שעל קבוצת המצבים הקלאסיים שלה סוכמים ושמכולחצת בין ברא ל-
קט כשלוקחים את העקבה החלקית על B למשל שמתוארת על ידי הנוסחה הראשונה אנחנו לפעמים אומרים ש-
B מועקב החוצה ובאופן דומה עבור A אינטואיטיבית לעקוב מערכת
החוצה פשוט אומר שאנחנו זורקים אותה או פשוט מתעלמים ממנה זו דרך אחת להגדיר את העקבה
החלקית ודרך שקולה אחרת היא לומר שההעתקות האלה הן ההעתקות הלינאריות היחידות שמקיימות את
הנוסחאות שמוצגות כאן מימין באופן ספציפי אם יש לנו מכפלה טנזורית של שתי מטריצות M ו-N נגיד
ואנחנו מבצעים את העקבה החלקית על המערכת הראשונה אז מה שנקבל הוא העקבה של המטריצה הראשונה M כפול
המטריצה השנייה והתנאי סימטרי כשעוקבים על המערכת השנייה לא כל מטריצה שנחשב
עליה את העקבה החלקית היא מכפלה טנזורית כזו אבל כל מטריצה ניתנת לביטוי כצירוף לינארי של
מכפלות טנזוריות ואפשר לקבוע את העקבה החלקית מהתנאים האלה יחד עם העובדה שאלה פונקציות
לינאריות וזו הסיבה שזה נקרא העקבה החלקית ההגדרה השקולה הזו יכולה להיות
מאוד מועילה כי לעיתים קרובות אפשר להשתמש בה במקום הנוסחה המקורית הנה דוגמה ש-
ממחישה את זה נניח שיש לנו זוג qubits במצב שמטריצת הצפיפות שלו מוצגת כאן על
המסך זו במקרה דוגמה של מצב מתואם שבו A הוא או במצב אפס או במצב אחד כל אחד
בהסתברות חצי אז אפשר לחשוב על A כקלאסי אם A במצב אפס אז
גם B במצב אפס ואם A במצב אחד אז B במצב פלוס אם רוצים לדעת מהו המצב המצומצם של A
עוקבים את B החוצה ואם משתמשים בנוסחה השנייה מההגדרה השקולה יחד עם לינאריות אז אפשר
לחשב את זה די בקלות בפרט העקבה של קט0 ברא0 היא אחד וכך גם העקבה של קט פלוס ברא
פלוס אז הגורמים הטנזוריים האלה נעלמים ונשארים עם המצב המעורב לחלוטין בצורה דומה אפשר לחשב
את המצב המצומצם של B על ידי עקיבת A החוצה הפעם זה הגורם הטנזורי הראשון שמבצעים עליו את העקבה אז
משתמשים בנוסחה הראשונה מההגדרה השקולה ונשארים עם חצי כפול קט0 ברא0 ועוד חצי כפול קט
פלוס ברא פלוס או במילים אחרות אותה מטריצת צפיפות שעלתה כמה פעמים קודם הייתם מקבלים בדיוק את
אותן תוצאות אם הייתם משתמשים בנוסחאות מההגדרה הראשונה אבל זו דרך הרבה יותר קלה לעשות את זה כל זה מוכלל לשלוש מערכות או
יותר אבל עבור הסרטון הזה אני הולך לעצור כאן ולהשאיר את זה לכם לשקול בעצמכם וזהו עבור השיעור הזה ש-
הציג מטריצות צפיפות ותיאר את הבסיס של איך הן עובדות דנו גם בכדור Bloch
וגם בסוגים שונים של קורלציות ובמושג של מצב מצומצם של מערכת אני מקווה שתצטרפו אליי ל-
שיעור הבא שעוסק בערוצים שהם העתקות לינאריות ממטריצות צפיפות למטריצות צפיפות ש-
מתארות פעולות על מערכות להתראות עד
אז